all right here we go finally I get my
ISO camera there's no wide shot we could
take I finally am on camera of one time
unbelievable so I'm very grateful
December 10th Andrew Jackson hero under
fire will finally be on at 8 o'clock
these guys did an incredible job putting
this together not only do look at
Jackson the war on at the Battle of New
Orleans but it is incredible life and
now he's front and center because if
everyone makes the comparisons with
President Trump the one thing I want to
share with you is they left me behind
the glass at his house at the Hermitage
Howard Keitel who runs things over
there's president/ceo he brought me to
it is essentially the trophy room this
is the things that mattered most Andrew
Jackson here's a little of it now this
is the front parlor of the mansion and
if you were coming to visit President
Jackson or former President Jackson he
you would have been invited to come in
here and wait for him and he would have
let you wait long enough to look at the
things he had in this room that would
tell you he's an important man so so get
this this is the thing in this room to
see the candle on the on the on the
table yeah that candle was slipped by
George Washington after the Battle of
Yorktown he sat down with his officers
he says everyone hold a candle I'm gonna
light it for you we made history and
hold on to this candle the rest of your
life well Jackson looked up to
Washington and when when one of the
officers there before he passed away had
to go give that candle to Andrew Jackson
himself and that fairy candle was held
by George Washington handed to Andrew
Jackson and sat out on a table and that
sits at the Hermitage in that yeah yeah
was it was delayed because I'm not sure
but it's get back on you you've only
been on TV three hours